[Music]
on August 9th 2018 a fighter jet dropped
a bomb on this street in Dyanne Yemen it
exploded here near a busy marketplace
killing 40 children on a school bus
the plane was from a coalition led by
Saudi Arabia they've conducted thousands
of airstrikes in Yemen since 2015
many aimed at civilian targets this is
the bomb and this photo reportedly taken
after the attack shows that the serial
number 9:47 one corresponds to a
500-pound laser-guided bomb built by the
Lockheed Martin corporation it was made
in the United States in fact most of
Saudi Arabia's weapons are the u.s. is
the biggest arms dealer in the world and
Saudi Arabia's its number-one customer
for nearly 75 years the two countries
have been strategic allies trying to
keep the Middle East stable for their
own benefit but today the Middle East
has fallen apart and Saudi Arabia has
been using US weapons to make him worse
so why does the US sell Saudi Arabia so
many weapons and will it ever stop
[Music]
it all started with oil in 1938 a lot of
it was discovered in the new country of
Saudi Arabia or here are more proved and
readily accessible reserves that in all
of North and South America together in
1945 US President Franklin Roosevelt
made a deal with the Saudi King
Abdulaziz al-saud the Saudis would
provide the u.s. with a safe reliable
source of oil and in exchange the US
would support and protect the Saudis
this was at a time when the US was
making other alliances in the Middle
East well however together with its
strategic location does made this area
important in world affairs but at first
u.s. arms sales to their allies in the
Middle East were limited the us hoped
fewer weapons would mean less conflict
and therefore a steady supply of oil but
that didn't last for long war broke out
between Israel and these Arab states in
1967 this put the u.s. in an awkward
position it had allies on both sides the
u.s. ultimately decided to sell fighter
jets to Israel to give them an advantage
over the Arab states but war broke out
again six years later this time the US
sent thousands of tons of arms to Israel
this outraged the Arab allies including
Saudi Arabia so they struck back the
oil-producing countries of the Arab
world decided to use their oil as a
political weapon these Arab states cut
off oil supplies to the US to protest
their support of Israel and it caused a
crisis the price of oil nearly
quadrupled in the US the cut-off ended
several months later when the u.s.
brokered a peace deal between Israel and
Egypt but to help rebuild its
relationship with its Arab allies the
u.s. decided to sell them weapons and
the Saudis were particularly eager to
buy by the 1970s oil profits had made
Saudi Arabia's monarchy extraordinarily
rich and they could afford to buy a
range of advanced weapons between 1970
and 76 US sales to Saudi Arabia
skyrocketed in the meantime just across
the Gulf Iran had a
urged as another extremely strategic
allied to the US like Saudi Arabia it
was a large oil-rich country but more
importantly it shared this long border
with the Soviet Union America's primary
enemy during the Cold War so President
Nixon said the US would Celeron
virtually any conventional weapons that
wanted together
Saudi Arabia and Iran became America's
twin pillars in the Middle East for the
u.s. selling them guns bombs planes and
tanks was a way to prevent the Soviets
from entering the Middle East and
protect the oil supply and having these
countries rely on American weapons gave
the u.s. important leverage to dictate
how and when they were used it was also
an important sign of trust and support
between allies us arms came with years
of training and maintenance
so each weapons deal with Saudi Arabia
for example was a long-term commitment
to work together this would prove to be
important because Saudi Arabia in the
u.s. would soon have to rely even more
on each other in 1979 the islamic
revolution overthrew the pro-us Shah of
Iran who was replaced by a religious
leader Ayatollah Khomeini suddenly one
of America's twin pillars turned on it
the new Iran was ambitious and extremely
anti-american while armed with nine
billion dollars worth of american-made
weapons and it was also the enemy of
Saudi Arabia each saw itself as the
leader of the Muslim world and started
competing for influence in the Middle
East so Saudi Arabia continued to want
more weapons and the u.s. continued to
sell them in the meantime Soviet Union
which had been developing its own
alliances in the Middle East for decades
started selling advanced weapons to
countries like Iraq and Syria at this
point a full-scale arms race was taking
place in the Middle East and Saudi
Arabia was the biggest buyer thanks to
the US I do not think it contributes
towards achieving peace in the Middle
East and therefore I think this arms
sale should be disapproved these sales
sparked fierce debates in the u.s. like
on June 5th 1986 when President Ronald
Reagan supported the sale of 2,500
missiles
Saudi Arabia our proposed arms sales to
Saudi Arabia will increase the Saudis
ability to withstand the threat from
radical Arab states many in Congress
were skeptical about selling more
weapons in the name of defense over the
past 30 years the United States has sold
over fifty billion dollars worth of
military weapons and services to the
Saudis more than we've sold to any
nation on earth where are the reciprocal
acts of friendship Reagan argued that
the arms sales were an important part of
the Alliance and we have had for 140
years a relationship and an agreement
mutual security agreement with the Saudi
Arabians and it has been beneficial to
both of us he insisted that it was
important that the u.s. be the ones to
sell weapons to Saudi Arabia first of
all they're going to have arms whether
we do it or not but when they have them
from us there are restrictions on their
use of them and that they are restricted
to using them defensively or and there
are things that we will do it is not a
very valid argument but I can use the
same argument on drugs out in the street
if I don't sell someone drugs someone
else will the question is not whether
someone else will questions whether it's
right Congress pushed for some changes
to the deal before ultimately approving
the sale in fact Congress would never
fully block a foreign arms sale over the
next 20 years the strength of the
us-saudi alliance will waver but their
reliance on each other never quite
stopped
the Soviet threat vanished when the
country collapsed in 1991 but Iraq under
Saddam Hussein emerged as a new threat
to both Saudi Arabia and the US so the
Saudis went all out in 1993
the US and Saudi Arabia agreed on a
record number of arms sales but arm
sales decreased during the late 1990s
and hit rock bottom after the 9/11
attacks 15 of the 19 hijackers were
Saudi citizens two years later the u.s.
launched a war in Iraq and through the
Middle East into chaos returned to Saudi
Arabia as a partner and arm sales
started increasing again over the next
decade the Middle East continued to fall
apart and Iran took advantage of the
chaos by supporting militant groups in
Lebanon Syria and Iraq turning these
conflicts into proxy wars to the US this
is Iran destabilizing the Middle East
but to the Saudis this is Iran closing
in on them so Saudi Arabia started using
its weapons aggressively along with the
coalition of allies Saudi Arabia
intervened in Yemen's Civil War and 2015
the Saudis claim they wanted to restore
the government but only made the
conflict worse Iran stepped in to
support the rebels turning Yemen into a
proxy war the Saudis aggressive tactics
have created the worst humanitarian
crisis in the world out of nearly 16,000
airstrikes since 2015 the Saudi
Coalition has hit civilian targets a
third of the time most estimates put the
civilian death toll well over 10,000 the
UN has found that many of the civilian
attacks were intentional and could be
considered war crimes the problem is the
US has continued to sell arms to Saudi
Arabia this whole time in fact the Obama
administration approved the most arms
sales to the Saudis in US history
these included not just new weapons but
also replacements for weapons used or
damaged and
including this bomb likely sold to Saudi
Arabia in 2015 and dropped on a school
bus in 2018 three billion dollars five
hundred and thirty three million dollars
five hundred and twenty five million
dollars while the Trump administration
focuses on the supposed economic
benefits of selling weapons it misses
the real point decades of arming Saudi
Arabia was supposed to give the u.s.
some leverage over but that's clearly
not working Saudi Arabia's leader Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman is accused of
ordering the brutal murder of a us-based
journalist Jamal khashoggi and has
sparked historic resistance to the
us-saudi relationship I will not support
arms sales until all responsible for the
death of mr. Khashoggi have been brought
to justice and I will no longer support
the war in Yemen has constructed the
bombing of a school bus full of children
and other civilian targets is not
something I want
America's fingerprints on so will the
u.s. actually stop selling weapons to
Saudi Arabia it's a difficult question
the Middle East is more unstable than
ever after 75 years Saudi Arabia and the
u.s. still need each other but it's
clearly not a trustworthy alliance
anymore
[Music]